vote Democrat or you're a racist that's
the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now have you noticed a growing Trend in
America
white supremacist organizations are
popping up all over north south east
west racist groups are gaining traction
now I'm talking about white supremacist
book clubs white supremacists bowling
leagues white supremacist Garden clubs
even edgy new fashion trends for white
supremacist Spring Breakers
they're a white supremacist daycare
centers where the snacks are obviously
white rice milk yogurt potatoes you get
the point
now if you believed any of that turn off
the TV go to bed and call your doctor in
the morning
of course all this is ridiculous
true white supremacists real racists
have been thankfully shunted to the
extreme fringes of society
but to listen
regrets messaging in 2024. you think our
name is about to be taken over by men
and
men and one there are no white hoods and
these supposed racists are black and
brown people
being Hispanic or being black does not
or being anything does not make you
immune from being racist from being
radicalized from being a white
supremacist part of understanding the
Latino blog is understanding that we too
can be racist we too can fuel white
supremacy we've seen a number of
individuals who are clearly Latino or at
least of Latino Heritage who are
White supremacists
well of course racial bias exists it
always will sadly and it does to this
day but what the press surrogates for
the Democrats are getting at here goes
much deeper this is an effort to inflate
its prevalence or to excuse or deflect
from the destruction wrought by Democrat
policies
where in our cities are schools the
culture the economy everywhere
so rather than offer real solutions the
left returns to its dog-eared Playbook
racism is systemic it's structural and
it somehow explains why parents and
students even ones who are minorities
themselves are complaining about sexual
propaganda in our schools
now the speakers you're about to hear at
the Montgomery County Maryland school
board meeting are what the left
considers the new white supremacists I'm
here to testify on behalf of my
elementary age cousins they are
encouraged to wear Pride clothing and
rainbow wigs that seems odd to me as I
don't remember a Jewish day where we
were all encouraged to wear a kippa or a
Christian day where we all
where we were encouraged to wear a cross
or a Muslim day where all kids were
encouraged of your testimony
yeah
he's a young Muslim former student now
the new Bullies Are the racial and
sexual propagandists who defame anyone
who disagrees with their Twisted Mission
as white supremacist
there are over 40 kids that I know who
don't want to learn this and really want
to be here talking today but can't
because they are being bullied they are
the ones being bullied when they say we
don't want to learn this they are the
ones being bullied when they say this is
wrong they are the ones being bullied
when they say this is against my
religion
another young Muslim American
now it's appalling that anyone has to go
through this which brings us to TL
typical leftist Christian mink
now this is the type of angry feminist
who uses her County position as the
ultimate power trip
this issue has unfortunately put it does
put some not all of course but some
Muslim families on the same side of an
issue as
white supremacists and outright bigots
now if you can stomach it look in the
mirror sweetie because you're the bigot
an anti-religious fanatic who has no
business near our schools
now who's more eloquent Ms mink or the
students should prefer to silence
the issue of gender and sexuality are
influenced by our faith and we should
not be caricatured as intolerant
intolerance of the faith community
threatens their Road support for
Religious Freedom therefore eroding the
benefits it provides for everyone
now remember
to question the left's cultural Marxism
is to be called white supremacist pure
and simple or of course anti-gay to
question quotas well the same thing
zei does not mean Dei it means black and
gay people frankly that's what it means
it's a fear of the other
fear of the other
well by now it's pretty obvious right
that the Democrats knew once Biden was
elected America would be in for a lot of
suffering and a lot of sacrifice
so what's a political party to do to
stay in power at that point everything's
going down the tubes we all know it it's
to smear anyone and everyone who gets in
their way even if it means alienating
some of their traditional supporters
Latinos Muslims even blacks
now we see this in their attacks on Ron
DeSantis as well last year he was
re-elected with major support among
Latinos in his State remember he won by
20 points overall so how to beat him in
the presidential contest pretty popular
guy right well use the white out
strategy focus on his laws against
critical race Theory and sexualized
curricula use your press buddies then to
frame it all as rank bigotry
on May 20th this headline blasted across
the internet
the NAACP issues a travel advisory for
Florida now the obscene idea that the
state is hostile to Black Americans yeah
this is part of the plan then three days
later stick with me a gay rights travel
advisory okay just along with one
warning immigrants not to head to the
Sunshine State as well notice they left
out the term illegal
then came the crown and Glory from that
bunch of frauds over at the Southern
Poverty Law Center it's a leftist front
Group by the way that exists to smear
conservatives
they put the benign group moms for
Liberty on their extremism list
now of course if any group is extremist
and should be on that list it's the splc
itself
so this is all coordinated
the Human Rights Campaign declared a
state of emergency then Nationwide for
lgbtq people don't leave your homes then
today obviously uh feeling left out of
all the fear-mongering the Associated
Press of all places runs with this story
claiming that gay and black kids now
feel less safe in schools
you see this right don't you
this is all carefully orchestrated it's
a disinformation campaign meant to
intimidate good people from speaking out
and those same good people from trying
to influence things like school boards
or their local governments
if kids feel Under Siege it's precisely
because groups like Gilson and HRC have
turned our educational institutions into
their own sick playgrounds for left-wing
Community organizing
and along the way they've shown their
own vicious intolerance against parents
and students of Faith who just want a
good education not indoctrination
but remember go back to the original
this is all the Democrats have to offer
in 2024. they're going to avoid
addressing things like The Invasion or
Southern border why the schools are are
so dangerous in the inner cities why the
kids aren't learning why they've fallen
behind instead they're going to keep
Fanning the fake white supremacy flames
domestic violent extremism is our
greatest threat right now and
regrettably we have seen a rise in white
supremacy the most dangerous terrorist
threat to our homeland is white
supremacy
you know what the most dangerous threat
to our homeland is how about a guy who
often can't think can't walk or can't
start a sentence being able to actually
start a nuclear war that's pretty scary
the party of FDR the party of JFK has
become a mockery of itself
soon it will be up to the voters though
won't it to see if they want to return
to economic growth and prosperity
or do they want more of this white out
acid that the left is slinging
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else